on a new show on wabc radio in new york
they are exploring the left-right divide
and major issues afflicting new york
city and beyond one of the co-hosts is
former new york congressman anthony
weiner he spent 18 months in confinement
for sexting with a 15-year-old girl he
was released in 2019 he says he's ready
to answer tough questions about his own
life the challenges facing the country
he's joining now our friend curtis
sleewa with a new show their co-host the
left versus the right
uh
anthony weiner thank you for being with
us curtis sleewa uh always good to see
you my friend
i guess the first question that i have
is you pled guilty anthony
to
sending obscene materials to a young
girl 15 year old girl you went you pled
guilty you served jail time
have you changed are you a different
person
well um
i think so i don't think anyone can go
through that kind of experience and i
think this is probably true of people
who have
been through other types of adversity i
don't think you go through that type of
experience and don't emerge change well
that's absolutely but anthony wait a
minute i think it's fairly anthony
that's an obscure answer i think so
either you know in your heart if you
changed or you know in your heart if you
didn't change
or do you can you assure people because
you're going to now try and draw in an
audience and they're going to want to
know if you've changed or not have you
changed
they they
they can judge for themselves
i'm sorry
i said they can judge for themselves i'm
not out to persuade you or anyone else
that i've changed i mean i i'm doing a
radio show and people can call and ask
me questions we did one this past
saturday where people had an opportunity
to call in and
where curtis asked me a bunch of
questions and i asked and answer the
best i can but in terms of like i'm
trying to draw someone no i'm not trying
to make someone
like me or someone be persuaded of any
particular outlook on me
we're going to have some conversations
about things going on in new york city
and other places and hopefully people
will tune into the show but i'm not
terribly interested in trying to make
them feel any differently about me
curtis i would say between the two of us
we have anywhere between 60 and 70 years
of talk radio experience under our belt
and we've been friends for a long time
um
one of the things about talk radio is
it's a heart medium in other words p you
you have to connect with with somebody
on on a visceral level because they
can't see you
and
i i'm listening to anthony's answer it
doesn't sound that convincing to me i
would think that if it was me i would
want to convince people that i am a
different person that i changed that i
learned my lesson that i'm i'm moving
forward in a different direction in my
life how did you feel about the answers
you got
well uh i actually did two weeks of
programming uh with anthony before his
life just
imploded he's a good talk show host he
reveals much of his feelings i feel he's
on solid ground our owner operator john
katzmattidis who as you know saved wabc
from the scrap heap there would never
have again have been wabc if he hadn't
rescued it believes in giving people a
second chance bill o'reilly i can run
through a whole list of people who are
my colleagues at wabc who he's given a
second chance he believes in that and
let's face it we need to give people a
second chance we saw that in the trump
administration when he cut the jail time
of so many people that we didn't realize
were being incarcerated 20 30 40 years
so i think all of us democrats and
republicans we have come to a conclusion
that if you've done your time if you
paid the price for what you did
it's time to come back into the fold and
i must tell you if anthony weiner had
not had his personal problems we
wouldn't have had bill de blasio for
eight years who single-handedly
destroyed our city anthony would have
been the mayor and i'm telling you
he would have done a much better job and
we've been friends for a long time i i i
would just recommend in the sense that
if it was something this serious that
there's got to be a let me fall on the
sword
admit and tell people what's different
about me at this point you know i would
think going to jail is different and
um this is what i learned this is the
help that i got this is how i'm i'm
showing you guys what you want if you
if you want you can tune into the show
and you can hear that
you're on my show now
i'm giving you the chance now i know but
you invited you invited i know you
invited me to come on and then you say
did you change yes and i answered the
question i said i i believe that i did i
believe this kind of experience would
change any person
and now you're having a conversation
with curtis with me sitting here about
my answer all i can do is give you the
answer brother
well that's your answer i would have
expected a little bit more sincerity a
little more heartfelt a little more
um repentant the word from
the word from latin means to change
one's heart um and i agree with curtis i
believe in i'm not the guy that calls
for cancer but it's not something
what i know what i and i i appreciate i
appreciate you having me on the show i
mean it's it's fun and i'm glad to be
here and i'm grateful to to courtesy and
i have a good show you know i've always
in my political life been more concerned
about things on brighton beach avenue
than brighton england this the we're
going to talk about new york city issues
but you know i'm of the belief that the
way you demonstrate that you've changed
is for other people to perceive it is
for other people to see that you that
you're dealing with the last words would
be
if you shout from the mountain here
the last words let me just finish my
time
time will prove me right or wrong if i'm
being heartfelt with you
well you know i perhaps shouldn't
perhaps you you should help duba prep
for the hannity show for your guests i'm
just giving you the answer as best i can
buddy okay and uh curtis you you're
working a lot curtis never stops working
if he's not on the air he's in the
subways he just never stops uh curtis
you're happy
with how's the audience responding i
have 10 seconds literally
oh great and listen in sean you listen
to talk radio and then you give me your
opinion because we have two full hours
and i'll get deep into the mindset of
anthony weiner as he is now i promise
you that joe i'll listen uh curtis we've
been friends a long time anthony i hope
you changed and godspeed will continue
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else